confinement oblige c'est à moins d'un
kilomètre de chez lui que jason part
s'entraîner accompagné de son premier
supporters son père
[Musique]
jason pratique le floorball freestyle
cela consiste à effectuer des mouvements
et des figures avec une balle et une
crosse et bien sûr la balle ne doit
jamais tomber une fois qu'on arrivait de
l'infas d'arcs de cercle
c'est là qu'on a commencé à aller plus
haut à faire fouetter la balle et puis à
passer derrière offert des plus grands
mouvements en fait au lit beaucoup
le freestyle est une variante du
floorball traditionnel un sport qui
ressemble beaucoup au quai sur glace
mais se joue en salle
jason connaît d'ailleurs bien les deux
j'ai commencé par du hockey sur glace
durant les ans n'ont qu'à l'âge de trois
ans et c'est vers 12 ans à peu près que
je me suis dit pourquoi pas changé en
fait et me tourner vers un autre sport
mais qui reste en même temps dans les
sports de cross j'ai découvert le
floorball vous que j'ai pu essayer et
j'ai tout de suite accroché en fait ça
m'a tout de suite plu
cela fait cinq ans qu'il pratique le
floorball en club à orléans
mais depuis le premier confinement ses
seules et plusieurs heures par semaine
qu'ils s'entraînent au freestyle une ont
froid aussi
en novembre il s'est inscrit à la
première coupe du monde en ligne de la
discipline et a terminé cinquième mais
je m'y attendais pas c'est sûr mais
aussi beaucoup entraîné puis je me suis
dit j'ai envoyé la vidéo comme ça faut
pour m'amuser pas vraiment pour montrer
que que même en france on peut on peut
aussi bien maîtrisé la crosse et donc je
m'attendais pas à aller aussi loin en
tout cas le floorball fait sa passion et
est maintenant le freestyle en plus quoi
donc s'il peut il peut continuer on sait
jamais quoi devenir pro pourquoi pas
encore jason le jeune prodige du
floorball fait aussi la fierté de son
club orléanais même confiné son coach a
tenu à le féliciter
merci beaucoup originaires des pays
scandinaves
le floorball freestyle a désormais son
représentant français et qui sait
jusqu'où il peut aller
j'espère trouver des sponsors assez
rapidement et puis continuer le
freestyle m'améliorer puis on va
participer l'année prochaine et pourquoi
pas viser le top 3
[Musique]